estos juegos han tenido una nutrida
participación de atletas
latinoamericanos que por el momento no
han logrado los resultados esperados
en este caso particular deben los
comités olímpicos de la región en
trabajar en fomentar más los deportes de
invierno sabiendo que en esta zona
quizás no están las condiciones dadas
para la práctica de muchos medios sí
precisamente en las características
pues digamos geográficas y climáticas de
la región desde la mayoría de los países
de américa latina hace que no sean los
deportes de invierno
parte de la tradición de las disciplinas
que se practican acá por lo general los
atletas que clasifican a juegos
olímpicos estamos hablando de atletas o
que se han ido a estudiar o hacer vida
en el exterior o atletas que tienen un
padre o una madre de alguno de estos
países latinoamericanos y apelan a esa
segunda nacionalidad que han ido a
estudiar a universidades del exterior y
son muy pocos los casos que se ven en
los que la participación del atleta se
obedece
a una preparación dentro de su país como
el caso de donovan carrillo el patinador
mexicano que sí se formó e incluso
entrena en pistas de centros comerciales
en guanajuato en su ciudad natal o el
caso de los patinadores colombianos que
el caso de pedro causil que participó en
los juegos olímpicos de plancha de hace
cuatro años o el de laura gómez que está
participando actualmente en estos que
fueron atletas
anteriormente de patinaje de velocidad
sobre ruedas y que participarán en un
programa del comité olímpico colombiano
para poder devenir en atletas de
velocidad sobre hielo